let's say i have some matrix a
if i'm trying to determine the null
space of a i'm essentially asking i'm
essentially just asking look if we set
up the equation
a x is equal to the zero vector the null
space of a the null space of a is all
the x's that satisfy this equation so
there's all
the x's
that satisfy
that equation ax is equal to the zero
vector or you could call it the system
and the way you would solve it and we've
done this many times this was many
videos ago you would make an augmented
matrix with this so the augmented matrix
would look like that you'd have the zero
vector on the right hand side and you'd
perform a bunch of row operations to put
the left hand side into reduced row
echelon form
so you would put do a bunch of
operations the left hand side would go
into reduced row echelon form let's call
that reduced row echelon form of a
and then the right hand side is just
going to stay zero because you perform
the same row operations but when you
perform those row operations on zero you
just get the zero vector right here and
then when you unaugment when you create
the system back from this right here
because these two systems are equivalent
you're essentially going to have your
solution set look something like this
you're going to have your
let me write it like this your solution
set is going to be equal to
some scalar multiple
you know let's say that of your free
variables your free variables are going
to be the scalar multiples and you've
seen this multiple times so i'll see it
stay fairly general but it's going to be
some multiple times let's say you know
vector one
plus
some other scale
scalar times vector two these scalars
tend to be your free variables
times vector two all the way to you know
i don't know
whatever c times your nth vector i'm
just trying to say general we haven't
seen any examples that had more than two
or three vectors here but this is what
essentially your null space is spanned
by these vectors right there
you get an equation you get a solution
set that looks something like that and
you call
you call that your null space we've done
that multiple times your null space is
that so it's all the linear combinations
or it's the span
of these little vectors that you get
here and one and 2
all the way to nn
this is nothing new i'm just restating
something that we've seen multiple
multiple times we've actually did this
in the previous video i just maybe never
wrote it exactly like this but what
about the case when you're solving the
inhomogeneous equation so the n
homogeneous equation looks like this
so if i want to solve
ax
is equal to
b i would do something very similar to
this i will create an augmented matrix i
have a on the left hand side and i'd put
b on the right hand side and then i'll
put i'll perform a bunch of row
operations to put a into reduced row
echelon form
so let me do that
so this left hand side will be the
reduced row echelon form of a and then
the right hand side whatever operations
i did on a i have to do on the on the
entire row so i'll also be doing them to
b
so i'll have some new vector here maybe
i'll call it maybe i'll call it the
vector
maybe i'll call that the vector b prime
it's going to be different than b but
let's just call it b prime
and so when you when you
go back to your i guess when you go out
of the augmented matrix world and
rewrite it as a system and you solve for
and we did this in the last video you'll
get your solution set
your solution set that satisfies this
is going to be x is going to be equal to
this b prime whatever this new vector is
this b prime plus
something that looks exactly like this
that looks exactly like that in fact
i'll copy and paste it it'll look
exactly like this
let me see if i if it
did copy
uh let me copy and paste it
edit
copy and let me paste it
so it looks something that looks exactly
like that and we said in the last video
we said in the last video that that
you can kind of
given this you can kind of think of the
solution set to the inhomogeneous
equation
is equivalent to some particular
solution
is equal to some particular solution
let's call that x particular some
particular solution plus some member of
your null space so you could say it's a
plus some homogeneous solution
so if you just pick particular values
for a b and c all of the different
multiples of the vectors that span your
null space you'll get some particular
homogeneous solution
so what i what i implied in the last
video and i didn't show it to you
rigorously is that any solution to the
inhomogeneous
system let me write it this way
any solution
and do it in white
any that's not white any solution
to
the inhomogeneous system
to in
homogeneous
genius
system
a
x is equal to b this is a claim i made
we'll take the form
we'll take
the form
some particular solution some particular
solution that was this right here maybe
i should do it in green
this is this right here and when you do
the reduced row echelon form it becomes
that b prime vector plus
some homogeneous solution
plus some homogeneous solution so some
member of the nulls place some member of
the null space now i didn't prove it to
you but i implied that this is the case
and what i want to do in this video is
actually do a little bit of a a more
rigorous proof but it's actually fairly
straightforward
so let's let's first of all verify that
this is a solution so let's verify that
this is a solution so let's just put
this into our original equation so if we
remember our original equation was ax is
equal to b
so let's verify so is
let me write it as a question
is
that particular solution plus some
homogeneous solution a
solution
a solution
to
ax is equal to b well to do that you
just put that in the place of x
so let's try it out
so a
times this guy right here times some
particular solution
plus
the homo sum homogeneous solution is
going to be equal to a times the
particular solution plus a times some
member of my null space and what is this
equal to that is going to be equal to b
right we're saying that this is a
particular solution to this equation
that is going to be equal to b
and that this is going to be equal to
the zero vector because this is a
solution to our homogeneous equation so
this is going to be equal to b plus 0
or it's equal to b so a times this
vector right here is indeed equal to b
so this is a solution
this is a solution yes
now the next question is does every
solution to the in homogeneous system or
does any solution to the inhomogeneous
system take this form
so does any
does any
solution
x
to
a x equal to b
take
the form
x is equal to some particular solution
plus a member of our null space or plus
a homogeneous solution so to do that
let's take
let's test out what happens when we
multiply the vector a
times
a times
a times x let's just let me write it
this way
let's say that x
x is
any
solution
to
a x is equal to b let's start off with
that and let's see what happens when we
take a times
x minus
some particular solution
some particular solution to this so when
we distribute the matrix vector product
you get a times our any solution
minus
a times our particular solution
now what is this going to be equal to
we're saying that this is a solution to
ax equal to b so this is going to be
equal to b
and of course any particular solution to
this when you multiplied by a is also
going to be equal to b
so it's going to be b minus b so that's
going to be equal to the zero vector
or another way to think about it is
x
the vector x minus
our particular solution
is
a solution
to
a times x is equal to zero think about
this
if you take this in parentheses right
here and you put it right there when you
multiply it times a you get the zero
vector we just did that you get the zero
vector because when you multiply each of
these guys by a you get b and then you
get b minus b and so that you get zero
so you can say that
x minus so are any solution x minus the
particular solution of x
is
is a member
a
member
of our null space of our null space
right by definition your null space is
all of the x's that satisfy this
equation and let's say so since it's a
member of our null space we can say that
it is equal to
so our any solution minus our particular
solution is equal to some member of our
null space we could say that it's equal
to a homogeneous solution
there might be more than one a
homogeneous
solution
a homogeneous solution
now if we just
add our particular solution to both
sides of this we get that any solution
remember we assume that x is any
solution to this that any solution is
equal to our homogeneous solution is
equal to a homogeneous solution plus
plus a particular solution or plus our
particular solution so we've proven it
both ways that this this is a solution
to our inhomogeneous equation and that
any solution to our inhomogeneous
equation takes this form
right here now why am i so why am i so
concerned with this you know i've been
kind of fixated on this inhomogeneous
equation for some time but we've been
talking about the notion of of a
transformation being one to one
a transformation being
one to one that was one of the two
conditions for a transformation to be
invertible now to be one to one so let
me draw a transformation here
so let's say this is my domain
x
and this is my codomain right here
y
and i have a transformation that maps
from x to y
i have a transformation from the mass
from x to y in order for t to be one to
one so
i'll write like this one
two one in order for t to be one to one
that means for any b that you pick here
for any b
for any
b
that is a member
of our codomain there's at most
at most
one
solution
to
a
times x and i'm assuming that a is our
transformation matrix so we can write
our transformation t
as being equal to some matrix times our
vector in our domain so this would be a
x if this is x right here so t would map
from that to that right there so in
order for our transformation to be one
to one that means you pick any b here
there has to be at most one solution to
ax is equal to b or another way to say
that is that there is at most one guy
that maps into that element of our
codomain there might be none so there
could be no solutions to this but there
has to be at most one solution
now we just said we just said that any
solution to an inhomogeneous
so we just said that any let me write it
in blue any solution
takes the form
takes the form if there is a solution so
if there isn't a solution that's fine
that'll still satisfy one to one so but
if there is a solution any solution is
going to take the form
x particular plus
a member of a plus a member of your null
space plus a with this guy right here is
a member of the null space
this this thing right here just applies
to that guy right here any solution if
they exist if there are no solutions
that's fine you can still be one to one
but if you do have a solution you can
have it most one one person that maps to
it and any solution will take this form
we just i just showed you that now in
order to be one to one this can only be
one solution the solution set can only
be one solution this can only be
can only
be
one solution
we can only have one solution here right
which means what does that mean that
means that our that this guy right here
cannot be
more than one vector it just has to be
one vector this is only there's only one
particular solution right there but this
guy right here has to be
well there's for for any solution set
depending on how you define it there's
only one particular vector there but
this guy the only way that you're only
going to have one solution is if your
null space the only way you're going to
have one solution is if your null space
is trivial if it only contains the zero
vector your null space will always at
minimum contain the zero vector in the
last video i think i you know just off
the cuff that oh your null space has to
be empty but no your null space will
also will always by definition by the
fact that it is a
subspace it will always contain a zero
vector you can also always multiply a
times zero to get the to get zero so
your null space will always contain that
but or don't have only one solution your
null space can only have the zero vector
so that this can only
be zero and so that your only solution
is going to be the particular solution
that you found depending on how you got
there but it's only going to be your
particular solution so let me put this
this way
so if you
so one to one in order to be one to one
in order to be one to one
your null space
of your transformation matrix has to be
trivial it has to contain
only
only the zero vector
now we've covered this many many videos
ago what does it mean if your null space
is only contains the trivial vector let
me make this clear so
if your transformation vector looks like
this a1 a2
all the way to a n
and you're multiplying it
times you know x1 x2 all the way to xn
and the null space is all of the x's
that satisfy this equation zero and
you're going to have m
zeros right there
so if your null space is trivial and
we're saying that that is a condition
for this for you to be one to one for
your transformation to be one to one the
transformation that's specified for this
by this matrix if your null space is
trivial what does that mean that means
that the only solution to
another way of writing this is
a1 let me write this x1 times a1 plus x2
times a2 all the way to xn
times a n is equal to
the zero vector
these are equivalent statements right
here i just multiplied each of these
terms times these respective column
vectors these are the same things now if
you say that your null space has to be
equal to zero you're saying that the
only solution to this equation right
here the only scalars
that satisfy this equation
oh sorry these aren't let me actually
because i wrote the scalars as vectors
so this guy right here this statement
right here is equivalent to x1 times a1
plus x2 times a2
plus all the way to xn times a n is
equal to the zero vector where the x1s
through xn's are scalars now if we say
the null space is 0 we're saying the
only way that this is satisfied is if
your x1
all the way to xn is equal to 0
and this means this is our definition
actually of linear independence that
means that
a1
so the null space being 0 also means
that your column vectors of a
your column vectors let me write it this
way
it also means that a1 a2
all the way through a n
are
linearly
independent
independent now what does that mean if
all of these guys are linearly
independent
what is
what is going to be the basis for your
column space remember the column space
is the span
the column space of a is equal to the
span
of a1 a2
all the way to a n well we just said if
we're if we're dealing with a one to one
or or one of the conditions or the
condition to be one to one is that your
null space has to be zero if or only
contain the zero vector if your null
space contains a zero vector then all of
your columns are linearly independent if
all of these columns span
span your column space
and they're linearly independent they're
linearly independent then they form a
basis so that means
that a1
a2 all the way to a n
are a basis
for
our column space
and then that means if all of our column
vectors here are linearly independent
they obviously span our column space by
definition and they all are linearly
independent they form the basis so the
dimension of our
basis so the dimension
of our column space
the dimension of our column space that's
essentially the number of vectors you
need to form the bases it's going to be
equal to n we have n columns so it's
going to be equal to n or another way to
say it is that the rank
the rank of your matrix is going to be
equal to n so now we have a condition
for something to be one to one something
is going to be one to one if and only if
if and only if the rank of your matrix
is equal to n and you could go both ways
if you assume if you assume something is
one to one then that means that it's
null space here has to only have the
zero vector so it only has one solution
if it's null space only has the zero
vector then that means its columns are
linearly independent which means that
they all are part of the basis which
means that you have n basis vectors or
you have a rank of n you go the other
way if you have a rank of n that means
that all of these guys are linearly
independent if all of these guys are
linearly independent then the null space
is just the zero vector and then that if
the null space is just the zero vector
this part of your solution disappears
and then you're only left with one
solution so you're one to one so your
one to one if and only if the rank
the rank of your transformation matrix
is equal to n